ja fast 7 Monate Krieg in der Ukraine
und großes passiert im Osten Russland
ist auf dem Rückzug wir wollen uns die
Karte der Ukraine einmal ansehen wie sie
jetzt aktuell aussieht und wir erinnern
uns die roten Gebiete hier die roten
Gebiete sind die russisch besetzten
Gebiete und hier oben in der
nordöstlichen Region rakiv dort hatten
wir noch bis vor einer Woche nicht mal
einmal dieses ganze Gebiet ja auch in
rot das ist alles mittlerweile von den
Ukrainern befreit ein Gebiet doppelt so
groß wie das Saarland das muss man sich
vorstellen tatsächlich innerhalb von nur
einer Woche befreit worden von den
ukrainischen Einheiten die dort
vorgerückt sind zuerst eben mit
militärischen Mitteln indem man
tatsächlich die großen beschossen und
vertrieben hat dann aber große Flucht
angetreten Befehle aus Moskau 1000
russische Soldaten ziehen ab und wir
sehen uns das mal an wie das aussieht
wenn ihr abziehen das sind
drohnenaufnahmen der Ukraine wir sehen
hier ein Fluss den Fluss ostkol und hier
eine Brücke der Russen und hier sieht
man den allerersten LKW und wir bleiben
da einfach mal drauf und sehen uns das
an und wir sehen das ist nicht ein LKW
es sind hunderte LK hier geht die Straße
lang immer weiter Kilometer lang ziehen
die Russen hier ab das ist der Rückzug
aus der Stadt isium da sehen wir es
wieder immer mehr vielleicht hören wir
es auch die ukrainische Soldaten können
es gar nicht glauben die sind ja am laut
lachen darüber was ihre Drone hier
entdeckt hat es ist tatsächlich ewig
weit immer weiter ja die Straße hier
runter da sehen wir wieder dutzende
Fahrzeuge der russischen Armee es sind
hunderte Fahrzeuge die sich
zurückgezogen haben das ist alles was
die Russen nach mobilisieren konnten für
den Abzug können uns das einfach mal
hier angucken 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 nur da zu
sehen das sind die Fahrzeuge mit denen
die Russen noch abgezogen sind einige
schwere Waffen ihre Panzer ihre
Schützenpanzer vor allem ihre Artillerie
und ihre Munition mussten sie
zurücklassen ganz klar die konnten sie
nicht abziehen aber ansonsten mit allem
was ich noch bewegen ließ ganz schnell
haben sie sich etwa 50 km zurückgezogen
über den flussoskol und sind jetzt
weiter ja in im Osten der Region rakiv
wir wollen es auch mal angucken dass
welche
Propaganda entlarvt wurde russische
Propaganda die entlarvt wurde durch
diese Offensive wir sehen hier ein
russisches Propaganda Plakat angebracht
in der Ostukraine da steht drauf
Russland und wir sind ein Volk und wir
sehen natürlich was der ukrainische
Soldat damit macht nämlich erreicht das
runter weil natürlich sind die Russen
und die Ukraine kein Volk sondern zwei
Völker zwei Staaten zwei einzelne
Nationen die unabhängig voneinander sind
aber diese Propaganda das Russland sagt
die ostukrainer die sind doch genau ein
Volk wie wir die ist schon acht Jahre
alt mindestens seit Putin angefangen hat
dort kriegt zu führen und wir sehen uns
das aber man und sehen auch hier Videos
die das nämlich entlarven und wir hören
mal genau hin die Menschen dort das sind
die Dorfbewohner die befreit wurden die
rufen danke und zwar auf Russisch
spasiba spasiba rufen Sie immer wieder
und wir hören dann die Ukrainer die
bedanken sich die ukrainischen Soldaten
die bedanken sich für die Blumen die sie
kriegen und sie rufen da ja Kojo yakuju
und das bedeutet danke auf ukrainisch
und wir sehen und hören
[Musik]
genau und wir sehen einfach mal diese
Sprachbarriere die angebliche die in
dieses Land ein zweit angeblichen Osten
der für die Russen ist und Westen der
für die Ukraine ist das ist eben
völliger Blödsinn die Menschen hier sind
russischsprachig zu allergrößten Teil
russischsprachig im Osten der Ukraine
bedanken sich auf Russisch bei den
ukrainischen Soldaten bei ihren Soldaten
die sie befreit haben wir von der
russischen Besatzung und als
allerletztes wollen wir uns noch
interessante Aufnahmen ansehen die
Russen sind so schnell geflüchtet dass
in vielen Orten die ukrainische Armee
überhaupt nicht ankam die kam gar nicht
so schnell an wie die Russen weg waren
und die Leute haben einfach gesagt na ja
wenn ihr kein Russe mehr da ist unsere
Armee ist noch nicht da dann hätte ich
doch unsere Flagge selber auf dem
Gebieten die bisher von den Russen
besetzt waren wir sehen hier ein
Dorfbewohner in der Nähe der Grenze der
eben selber sich seine eigene
ukrainische Flagge schnappt die am
monatelang versteckt hatte und die
festmacht hier sehen wir auch ein
weiteres Rathaus in einer Stadt in der
im Osten auch hier die Russen sind alle
weg die Ukrainern sind nicht da ja was
hat sich der Ukrainer gedacht die
russische Flagge die 6 Monate angepasst
war die sage ich erstmal in den
Papierkorb und warte bis dann zwei Tage
später war es dann soweit tatsächlich
die Ukrainer kamen und eben diese Stadt
die von großen verlassen wurde einfach
so Hals über Kopf eben dann wieder
zurückerobert haben das also die Lage im
Osten der Ukraine militärisch ein
Desaster für Russland aber eben auch
propagandistisch weil man eben sieht
dieser angebliche Kriegsgrund für alles
wir sind da um die Russen zu retten da
gibt es in keine Russen da gibt's
ausschließlich ukrainische Staatsbürger
russischsprachig die aber mit ihren
Ukraine
Staatsbürgern und Soldaten einer Meinung
sind
[Musik]